[музика]
хочу сказати що носив без ради варто не
коди
цигана петя танки місць не структурам і
крадуть бтр та авторозбору до 2 beta ера
видно за нитку українська армія з наших
солдатів же називаю їх бум жанни
жертовним а шо
там у військовому плані ми по вниз
рації
[музика]
ти йшов маскою по
приходу
[музика]
чим в анал
to play all
маз
знімай
хто я взагалі
все про я арно
прямо так пацани від ринку самому
риби на
чорнозем українські сумської області їх
вже не випустив ось вони тут і про
паркувалися на стояночку
платну
горбатий я сказав горбатий
горбатий вихід
морда чеканя крок йдуть військовослужбовці
повітрянодесантних військ парадний розрахунок
рязанського bar disco вищого
повітряно-десантного командного училища
імені генерала армії маргелова
очолює начальник училища
полковник руслан не входи move його
випускники за рівнем професійної
підготовки пил і залишаються одними з променів
в
збройних силах Росії
[музика]
прямо на email
нам
[музика]
red nose
охололо
письменника ticket дай ми не 10 довгих
ірпенський міст і не далі підірвав і
засунути і левін стоятиме то я вам
гарантую
вам підібрати буде рубати за кухоль
води та буханець хліба блять видно
неправда дорожню руку йдуть за ми
слизьким кораблем можна постригти
зошити на зустрічі інші хотілки основна
мета дістати і гуманітарку зростання
барабану вона червона обидва проти спекотніша
чим тягнути поки що діти мої пацани zara про
чуев задіяні quiz людей на кордон
гуманітарку травлячись ти в 5 разів 5
[оплески]
допив матч ящиків на тій данини всі свої
ж
[оплески]
Україна
доброго ввечері з України
хочу парада ти одному вбивці траху
кадирову ще я тут ще на мо ти твої
шакали скоро і нудизм і себе замлі
органи пройшовши українці сильно нація тому
ми допоможемо
слава нації
смерть вороха
[музика]
нові
[оплески]
mondo
УкраїнаУкраїна
будь м'язами не наші дай мені те, що я
приїду заворуїв і фронт робіт не всі
падаю все добре і ми влаштуємо
влаштуємося міста яся ви обидва чаю пацани
бача ви на місцями квітки будуть на
гуцули з франківська
вигули що це бенді rivets від нас хоче
хочеш і висловили слова впали нитки по
ломитися
поляниця
ясно я zara zara лондон і полінуватися і
до впали ниць і диверсанти з rania
тарабара макєєва я у вашу матір скажи
поляни ці обидва порожні в росію москаль
насрано спідницю і матч досвіду так можна трохи
не знаю я бачив у телеграмі що за
ротару барона так робот і туди, і домени
dice la tulipe шиша можеш статус з
хлопів жити у тільки за жінку стежку і в
польше від з пацанами в tyra moore
і
[музика]
і сам bamboo
я за на
б
[музика]
мені не соромно що я російська
де ти був 8 років коли бомбили мирне
населення донбасу
росіяни бомбити мирне населення
розбомблений у маріуполі рот тому це
була база азову де сиділи нацисти
всесвітній наркоман
росія та україна один народ
[музика]
ось
чоловік